(calming music)
Hi guys my name is Heinrich and
welcome to another coffee
break with firm learning.
Today the weather is beautiful in Munich,
we had a nice brunch this morning
together with a good friend of mine,
who is actually an entrepreneur,
he has a small company here in Munich
employing about forty people
and we talked about a new
employee in his company
that's a new guy he just left university
he has good grades,
seems to be quite good and confident
and actually being able
to do the jobs well.
However, for some reason
my friend doesn't seem
to be just satisfied with
what he is doing at work,
and we talked a bit about it
and what the reason might be
because it wasn't directly easy to grasp
and after some time we
came to the realization
that what this person was actually missing
was an ownership mindset.
So you may ask yourself what
is an ownership mindset?
An ownership mindset is a critical mindset
that on the one hand side
many new joiners and business lack,
if you come from university
often you do not have that
but on the other side this
is really what distinguishes
the average guy, the average professional
from somebody who really stands out
and is perceived as much better
than all of the other people in the team.
So an ownership mindset is if
you receive a task from your team leader
or another colleague and you
do not only try to somehow
get the task done but you
feel completely responsible
from end to end to getting to the result
that is really needed and
why is that maybe a bit
difficult for new joiners?
Because of course in the
beginning of your career
if you just started your
job in the early months
and maybe first one, two or three years
of course you are new,
you do not have all the
knowledge of the organization,
maybe you do not completely
understand everything,
so you to a certain extent
rely on your other colleagues,
you rely on others checking your work,
making sure that your work actually
has the quality that is needed
and that it just is the way
it is supposed to be right?
And of course to a certain
extent that's okay.
It's completely natural and
everybody will understand
that as a new employee you do not
know everything from the beginning,
you might even make mistakes,
maybe the quality of
your work is not as good
as maybe the work from
a more senior colleague.
However, the flip side of that is that
people start to rely
and to depend on that,
what I mean by that is that people
start to develop thoughts such as,
"Well my team leaders
reviewing after what's anyway",
"Well if my team leader has it and
he wants to change something,
well he can still do that, right?"
Or, "Well this is just a first draft,
I mean its just a first try for me,
let the others that maybe will refine it",
or, "After myself many other people
will still review the document,
will still have a look at it
and if there is anything wrong with that
then they will fix it, right?"
I mean this is more or less
consciously the mindset
that many people have,
especially in the
beginning of their career.
And the truth is that
many people do their work
knowingly that it's just not enough,
knowingly that the end
deliverable that they created
is just not meeting the standards
and just relying or just
assuming that other people
will pick up the slack,
that your team lead will then actually
give it a proper review and
then fix all the errors,
maybe change it to a
way and to a level that
is actually enough and sufficient for
actually what's required.
And again from the
perspective of your team lead,
while on the one side you of
course understand that maybe
a new joiner isn't as good as
somebody who is more senior,
of course this is annoying and
is really bugging your time, right?
And from my experience now
from working in consulting
what of course happens sometimes is that
you will trust another colleague
maybe a support colleague of
yours to get something done,
to do something and then
you receive the deliverable
and it's just obvious that this
is not client ready deliverable, right?
Its just obvious that other person thought
"Well, you know Heinrich in
the end is going to fix it,
or the other consulting
colleague is going to fix it,
and it's going to do all the
last changes that he maybe needs".
So it's clear then the moment
that the person created it,
it just wasn't done and
the person know right,
that it wasn't done and this
is something that you should
really avoid as a new joiner.
From very early on in
your career you need to
develop the mindset
that it's not only about
getting the to do's off your table,
right, pushing it out and
just somehow completing them,
but to make sure that
every little thing you do
is actually at the level
that it's complete,
that actually it wouldn't require
anybody else in your
team and organization,
neither colleague or your
team lead to do any changes
in order for it to be at a level
where it's at least
sufficient and okay, right?
Of course there are different perspectives
maybe you another colleague
has another opinion
and would like to change
something in it a bit,
but it should always be at the level
where you would feel
comfortable in actually handing
the deliverable to a client
or to an external party
or somewhere else where this actually
might be needed in the future.
An easy little mindset hack that I learnt
from my time at Mackenzie
that you can employ here
and that are taught to
early young consultants,
is that you should ask
yourself the following question
whenever you complete a
deliverable, a certain task,
a document or whatever you are working on,
are you confident that you
could send this document
to a board member of your client
and he would be okay by reading this
and nobody would lose face?
Are you confident that your work
is ready to being sent to a board member
of your organization
with your name under it?
If you are not confident
that your work deliverable
is at this level of quality
then very likely you just
haven't done yet what is required from you
and should go back and do that.
Of course it is great to have
other colleagues check your work,
to have a four eye principle,
to make sure that no mistake is left
or anything like that
but do not rely on them,
do not rely on other colleagues
getting your work done,
you are responsible for it,
you will deliver it,
and you will bring it to a quality that
you can send it to a board
member of your organization.
So what specifically can you do to develop
this ownership mindset and make sure that
your work quality is always
where it needs to be?
So just a couple of tips that I hope
are helpful to you right?
That the first thing is if
you find out that you actually
do not have information at hand
for you to complete the task
this of course happens frequently,
maybe you need other data,
input from other colleagues, right?
Don't just push over it
back to your team lead and
tell them, "Sorry I couldn't
complete it because I just
didn't have all the
information that I needed".
But reach out yourself to
these other colleagues,
to these other departments,
do some research, collect
everything you need
and then go back to your team lead
and tell them, "Well in
the beginning this wasn't
sufficient but I made
sure that I have all these
other inputs and now
this is the deliverable
that you really need".
Another example, imagine your
team lead came to you and
told you, you need to
create a certain document,
a certain thing and by
that you should include,
three certain graphs for instance,
three certain charts,
with a data visualization
that he felt like this is what's required
and helpful here but by
now crunching the numbers,
by digging into the work,
you find out that actually
these three things
that he asked you to
do are just not enough
and to actually understand
what is going on
and to really get the full
grasp of the situation,
it would just be required to include
a fourth diagram into the piece of work
that you are working on, right?
Now what many new joiners do is,
they just do exactly what they are told,
they create the document,
include the three diagrams
hand it back to the team lead
or the boss or whatever it's
called in your organization
and then they are like,
"Well, I did everything what
was asked of me," Right?
And yes of course you
did everything what has
been asked from you but in this instance
that just wasn't enough,
it just wasn't enough to send it to
a board member of your organization
because what the board member,
he just wouldn't have had the full picture
and obviously if your team
lead now is looking at it
and thinking about this he will likely
come back to you and ask you,
"Hey come on, you should
include the fourth thing
because this is just
important to do that,"
and then of course you can do that,
but it's always much better and perceived
much more professionally
if you think one step ahead
and directly include that
because you know that it's
required to include it
because nobody usually is
as deep into the details
of the specifics of the work
that you're currently
completing than yourself.
Very often in these situations it was just
not really possible for
your team lead to foresee
that things like that would have needed
to be included because he just wasn't as
deep as now you are
into the matters, right?
So to generalize this a bit more,
what's really important
is that you ask yourself,
what is actually the intention of this?
Why is somebody asking me to do something?
What is he hoping to get out of that?
And then you make sure
that the deliverable
that you produce actually
enables the other person
or whatever the audience
is for the things that
you are creating, the things
that you are working on,
to actually answer these questions,
these problems that they have.
If you're deliverable isn't helpful in
actually solving the problem,
or answering these
questions then make sure
to make all the changes and adjustments
in order to get there.
Right and of course if
you feel more comfortable
then go back to your team lead and say,
"Hey I did one, two,
three but now I feel like
in order for this to be really helpful,
I think I should do the fourth thing,"
just in case you really want to make sure
that he really agrees as your supervisor
but be proactive and ask that,
make that recommendation
yourself instead of waiting
for others to tell you what
you already know is required.
So guys this is really important,
if you want to be successful
in your early career
but of course also later on
develop an ownership mindset,
feel responsible for the
tasks that you're working on,
don't just complete to do's that
somebody else told you
to actually complete
but you are owning it,
you are making sure that the things
you are working on actually
are a great success,
if you do not adopt
this mindset it will be
extremely difficult for
you to be successful
in pretty much any organization,
in any industry you work on.
Get that done.
So if you took any
value out of this video,
please press the like button
and subscribe to my channel here below,
if you have any questions
please leave a comment here also below,
I will answer all your
questions that appear
in the comment section, I
would be happy to do so.
Of course if you have any feedback
or suggestions on future
videos let me know as well
and I will do my very best.
I have many pieces of content
planned for the future
so again if you do not
want to miss any of them
please subscribe here
and you will be then
informed whenever I produce.
Thank you for watching
and have a good day.